representative JJ pickle of Texas your
subcommittee recently did a study
showing that some American businessman
are willing to launder money why well
presumably because they don't want to
record me to the case transaction and in
effect not paying in taxes on that as
income years ago the Congress passed a
law that first made money laundering
illegal and then we amended it by
Section 60 50 I they said that business
must report these kind of cash
transaction and the law says that if any
merchant or institution is receiving
cash in excess of $10,000 that must be
reported to the Internal Revenue Service
so we are asking the merchants
the business people of the country to
simply fill out a form that if someone
incomes and wants to buy and look at
your item from them that all they got to
do to make a report of it their name and
address basic information so we had some
investors investigators go out the last
couple of months into nine different
cities in nine different states and
offered to buy these items Persian rugs
and automobiles and condominiums watches
and that type of thing and always said
we'd want to pay in cash the only way we
would have it and we wanted to know
would that be reported and we would
found out that they would take the cash
and not report it it was a rather
shocking thing to realize that in 79
different businesses that we wouldn't
these the investigators went into 76
said that they would take the cash and
not report it 76 out of 79 said give it
a cage and I'll not fill out this form
did that never surprise you that that
many were surprised it has shocked us
that realized that approximately 95
percent of the business
is in the country or would in to make a
sale and not reporting now you ask
yourself well did they know it did they
know the law
in most cases they indicated that they
knew there was a money-laundering law
had something to do with the drug
traffic but they would also go a step
further to say that we think you could
get around this law by giving us cashier
checks or structuring the sale in the
matter that they wouldn't have to make a
record of it in other words they knew
what the law was in most instances but
simply we're willing to circumvent the
law now do you do you assume that most
of the money we're talking about here is
money from illegal operations no we
can't assume that we know that if if a
individual money launderers go to a bank
by virtue of all we passed in Congress
they must make that report to the
Internal Revenue Service it's called a
CTR currency transaction Reform Act
they're doing that they weren't doing it
years ago the banks until we had a case
up in Boston where the Justice
Department brought a suit and got a
conviction and all it wants the banks
and the savings on found religion they
began to fill out these forms now we're
asking individuals to do that now to
help their government to know and we're
not trying to keep them from invading
involving in case sales but if they do
over 10,000 and here's why we do it if a
person comes in to you and say I want to
buy something for an automobile 50 to
our daughter but I only paid in case
there is a presumption that that cash is
coming from some source perhaps having
paid tax on it and that you're willing
to take it as a sale and not pay tax on
it and you are then hurting all
taxpayers when you do that so that is
really an invasion of the of the law but
merchants are willing to do it because I
think it just been the accepted thing to
do and nobody is a falling out to do to
change it and so it was a shocking it
really is a
grace that our businesses have allowed
this to to develop to this point
historically at least when we hear about
drug cases where this has come up before
we think of luxury items as you
mentioned cars and watches and some
other things but when you talk about I
think it was an antique shop also was
willing to do it that kind of surprised
me well antique items are usually
expensive items and many of them are
over the 10,000 mark but merchants are
willing to to say give me the cash it
got so bad in some cases that they knew
something about it give an example my
investigators went into Atlanta Georgia
and a Juris to rb1 and they said yes we
can sell these items we think we can
work with you they said a matter of fact
the Internal Revenue Service has been
looking at some of our books wondering
if we are engaging in these kind of
transactions says actually at this very
minute there's a couple of them in the
back of our store now checking our books
and we don't know if you don't mind it
said lower your voice is just a little
bit so they won't hear what we're
talking about nice and we can get around
the law this way now that's shocking so
it's it's one of our members said it's
the most shocking revelation that he has
seen since his play up to 15 years in
the Congress sure I assume that you
suspected this trend and that's why you
did the study yes we knew that it was
happening in the banking institutions
and we assumed that it was done so we
set out to find we just simply around a
test now we didn't try to entrap anybody
we just simply went out to these
merchants we had two people a man and
woman good capable investigators and
went in and said they want to buy all
these item and they looked at them and
then they offered them the case or to
give them the case no no money was
actually transacted and the merchants
would always say well we either we can't
do it and there's we they get ready to
leave they said but just a minute I
think we can help you work around your
problem this way so it seems to me like
it's a sort of a accepted procedure that
businesses are following and that hurts
everybody
and you say well or you really losing
any money for these things well I got
committee has given us figures based on
some of the internal revenue estimates
that we may be losing as much as thirty
billion dollars a year just a failure to
pay taxes on these cash transactions a
is the committee moving to correct that
what we have made some suggestions to
the after hearing yesterday to the
Internal Revenue Service and the justice
and the Treasury Department we have
given them three or four suggestions
where we think Corrections can be made I
think in general they are willing to to
endorse those changes and they're also
willing to make some investigation of
their own presence within the last month
now the Internal Revenue Service has
devised a new form the form we use now
is 8300 and that's all the merchants
bootiful I've got an 8300 to hear this
is an 8300 for now just a simple form
and said give me the name and the
address an amount of money that's
involved and the name and address of a
seller that's about all basically it is
but the Internal Revenue Service now
said they're coming up with a new form
both forms are new one after this the
investigation had been made we think the
getting into that pretty fast
they've also conducted a test in the
last month of their own as our incentive
went in to Birmingham Alabama and they
looked into at a hundred and thirty-one
books businesses and found that at that
about seventy nine of those p v cases
were willing to accept 69 79 except the
case on lower figure only about 60
percent another 90 but all they did was
as I said go in and just look at the
books and you see it you don't have to
report it if they are paid in a
cashier's check or a money order and
when they looked on the books and they
held catch they didn't count those so
their figures would have been a little
lower than I are but most Internal
Revenue Service and our committee both
agree that
the rate of compliance is mighty low
almost nil I would think it would be
very hard to correct because there are
just so many businesses I mean have to
go to every store not every store but
most every store that is capable of
something like that that has items that
cost that much but you'd be surprised
our committee suggested about nine or
ten different cities and we in order to
get a good spread throughout the country
I got a list of the city but we went
into nine different cities but we did
not tell the investigators who to call
on on what kind of business to call on
or how to go about it
they were a train and they just picked
out businesses at random businesses who
which would deal in luxury cars or rugs
or even realty companies antique shops
jewelry stores and just at random and it
went off out the street into the
businesses and asked them now they want
to buy this but they want to sell cash
and 76 out of 79 said just give me that
money that money talks and they said you
got to put a name down but give me any
name says Mickey Mouse if you won't -
and if it and nobody got rid of the if
he says well mr. Mickey you come by
tomorrow and we'll do some business with
you tonight we're talking about money
laundering our guest is veteran
representative JJ pickle from Texas who
represents the 10th district which
includes the City of Austin serving his
fourteenth term he's remember the Ways
and Means Committee and chairman of the
oversight subcommittee also serves on
the health subcommittee and the joint
Taxation Committee we'll be taking your
calls in just a few moments the numbers
of billets are out the show at the
bottom of the screen but we'll give them
to you at once here at the top if you're
calling from the eastern or central time
zones it's six to eight excuse me - OH -
6 to 8 25 25 that's - OH - 6 to 8 25 25
that's the number use if you're calling
from the eastern or central time zone if
you're calling from the mountain or
Pacific time zones it's 2 o-two 7 8 3 27
27 that's 202 7 8 3 27 27 and again the
30 day policy if you call
within the last month let's wait and
give some other folks a chance to get
through now the businesses that you went
to the 76 out of the 79 they've been
notified this action or what went on or
what's happening to them if anything no
we have not notified them and they
didn't go back the next day and accident
delivered the case but we have turned
all that information over to the
Internal Revenue Service who have said
that they will contact those businesses
as well as the the attorneys who they
say some of the business said they had
attorney own own own hire just to handle
these kind of cases so the information
has been turned over to Internal Revenue
Service
well the Drug Enforcement Agency get
involved in this because do you assume
that some of this money not obviously
the committee's but they will not bail
or dealing they will not have a primary
part in this part they would if there
were drug money we conducted this
investigation to see how businesses were
handing in their transaction some of it
may be drug money the source of it may
find out later but at this point he says
it's not a DEA operation this is just an
oversight we wanted to know how business
being conducted in the country in these
sales and we were shocked to find out
that they are just simply not being the
law I'd like to believe that most of
them feel that it's really acceptable
and it's part of the deal just go ahead
and make the sale and everybody looked
the other way but that's not the case
it's got if it represents a lot of money
you see a merchant who dealing who's not
making a record of it he's taking money
that may not have never had in tax paid
on it and he's taken a case just like
somebody gave you a hundred thousand
dollar check and you don't have to
report it that is evasion of tax that
hurts every good law-abiding the
taxpayer let's go to the phones Kingston
New York you're on the air okay go right
ahead if you could speak up a little bit
you're a little bit low why is it that
the American people should allow you to
raise your tax money by drawing it for
whatever means you can when you as the
government has shown the inability to
manage the funds that you do receive
well I guess that's a good question
they're not related to the problem the
salary we receive is one thing for the
service we've rendered the government we
are trying now to see that people comply
with the law certainly when we get a
check we have to pay your income on that
we're simply saying that if this is the
law of the land it should be enforced
would you say that we should not enforce
the law it's not that you should not
enforce the law but first of all you
should prove that you can manage the
money that you are received from the law
abiding I guess sir that that's what
we're trying to prove here we're trying
to prove that we we can prove our worth
by carrying out the law and see that it
is in law and I hope that our
enforcement agencies can prove that to
you go down to Birmingham Alabama
you're on c-span thank you sir right
ahead I have a question for mr. pickle
it seems to me and I'm just an ordinary
citizen retired it seems to me that
we're focusing in on a segment of our
citizenry it's almost an arm of the IRS
and policing certain aspects of business
transactions we already into that kind
of facet in collecting sales tax and
other taxes that we are required to do
and I apparently lit with the
proposition that the country of Rome
Italy has been in they've had about 25
different governments over there and
probably the most underpaid taxes in the
world is is in that country because of
the taxation and I just wonder if it
didn't put an undue burden on on the
citizenry well taxpaying people well the
as they showed you this form 8300 and
the Internal Revenue Service has said
they're going to try to simplify that
even more and all we're saying is that
if you do have a business transaction in
order be reported all we're trying to
find out is
people paying their fair share of taxes
you see we have a volunteer system and
if we don't collect taxes from the
illegal operation you and I and other
law-abiding citizens are going to be
paying more than our share now I grant
you that this is a form that have to
fill out and we ought to keep those to a
minimum and small businesses are they're
harassed constantly but having too many
forms so I recognize that but I would
think that if a business is being asked
to fill out a form it wouldn't take more
than five or ten minutes and he's
dealing in a sale of an item that would
be 50 to 100 thousand dollars that that
would not be much difficulty to fill out
so we do want to keep them busy minimum
but the only reason we're doing this and
we're trying to get taxes so that the
honest paying taxpayer will not have to
pay detectives for somebody else Palm
Desert California you're on c-span yes
good afternoon
buddy I like your program c-span and
also I am enjoying mr. pickles I would
like to know and that is why we don't
have a more conform program for the
people from foreign countries that are
over here earning good money from our
positions as far as offered by job
intervention in this country and they
aren't paying their fair share of taxes
is this part of our scam as far as
laundering money they get to spend money
at home to Mexico to Europe Spain
whatever we have ID numbers on our bank
accounts and we gotta pay tax on it why
don't they well they should and we are
looking into it
listen the problem of seeing that
foreign citizens are paying their fair
share or that foreign ministers is a
very difficult problem for it let me
give an example
my committee is investigating committee
and we have now underway an
investigation under what we call section
482 that is the case where a foreign
subsidiary owns a business in the United
States like let's say Japan we always
talk about Japan they send automobile
bills here and through transfer pricing
system
they are charged a high price for it and
send that money back to Japan or Germany
or England or wherever it might be
we are losing literally billions of
dollars because we're not collecting
from those businesses but they're kind
of taxes we're doing we're losing that
some with respect to the employees that
you mentioned I hope we can do better
that's one of the things our committee
is trying to look into
so you Bert you touched on a very timely
matter and I hope we can do better way
to go do Fairfax Virginia you're on the
air i watch many hearings our
congressman circles on TV and I watched
as much many others and it's what struck
me and I'd like to convey it to you I
was watching the hearings all I could
think about was neo Bush and the
Silverado what have you the island north
and secord Enterprise the Internal
Revenue and their Gestapo tactics and
the HUD scandals in the S&L scandal
tamela's made millions and millions of
dollars say nothing about Ronald Reagan
going to Japan in two million dollars or
whatever it's very difficult to get
incited or excited about something that
you are saying in this laundered money
feel I understand it
I don't certainly agree with it I do
agree with it but there are so many
things in this country that are billions
and trillions and destroying the country
that this is not even a little piece of
anything in the ocean well I don't know
that that we would say this is a little
drop in the ocean because if we're
actually losing some thirty billion
dollars in taxes that not being paid
that's no small item it is a model we'll
say to businesses but we're asking
business cooperation now I can't comment
or relate to these other matters you
mentioned mr. Neil Bush is a problem has
been aired and is being aired and he
will be asking that the courts and the
the our judicial system to settle that
and that's where it all to me I'm
speaking only with respect
I think we have a right to expect
businesses to pay their their taxes and
not to deal under the table because when
they do that
that's hurts you and me and every
law-abiding citizen go down to Bartow
Florida you're on the air thank you very
much mr. pickle I'm a little bit curious
but extremely extremely dubious of your
goals if I understand what you're saying
you're saying that if you can just get
these people making illegal money to pay
their fair share of taxes then you won't
be taken as much by money if is that
what you're seriously fighting no no no
not not at all
we'll be collecting money from men and
not just you you're paying the load of
the federal government and these other
people are not paying their fair share
that's all I'm saying you should pay
whatever you earn and whatever you can
deduct and what's left you pay tax on
that's all we're saying that and we're
not saying you can't deal in cash just
make a record of it because there is a
presumption that if you come in and say
I want to pay $50,000 for an automobile
that that you don't want to make a
record of that and you don't want
anybody to looking into it and you don't
want them to report it to anybody so it
won't be known now you sure they can't
condone that and that's what we're
trying to stop so that's the purpose of
our hearing and we found out that in our
investigation that this is true and you
know Internal Revenue Service and the
Treasury and the Justice Department have
all admitted yesterday to hearing that
we must put greater priority in the time
past what they had been going after was
the money launderer the big fellow that
had big satchel of money and we put it
in the bank and nobody would ever know
it we haven't been looking at the
merchants because we just didn't want to
think that businesses were also doing
this now this does not mean at all
merchants but it it's it's a pretty much
an indictment when 76 out of 79 said
that we will deal with you the that
doesn't speak well very well for the
business community per se I'd like to
point out that the three businesses that
didn't go along were a jeweler in New
York City and a car
dealer and another jeweler in
Minneapolis yeah that's right
three amending and in the district
Columbia now and I'm we broadcast him
for Washington we found out this last
year yep from now that only three of
these 8300 farms have been found filled
out three in the district Columbia
meaning that just nobody here and that
nobody bought a car over ten thousand
and paid cash for it or drugs and
there's much of that going into place
where only three that means it's a
complete listening let me go further in
the case here involving a drug
trafficker in which was tried last year
rayful Edmonds our committee read the
court records and went out and talked to
the merchants based on the court
proceedings and asked if he had made the
reports they said they had not filled
out the reports that hadn't been turned
over to Internal Revenue Service they
had not filled out these 8300 and that
it wasn't a matter of he failed to do it
they had knew they were dealing with
people in this kind of business and yet
we're not doing it so here here was a
concrete evidence and not just money
that was verbally offered but
transaction that took place and so it
seems to me that here in Washington DC
in much an in place in the country
there's a almost complete disregard for
filling out these form three of them
only you mean to tell me only three
merchants and in a metropolitan area of
a four million people didn't sell any
out and over ten thousand engage come on
that's that's not a fact go to Santa
Rosa California you're on the air mr.
pickle yes sir how are you sir oh just
finding yourself good I have just a
couple of statements that I'd like to
make and then also to be followed up by
one question
now the it's obvious we do need an
Internal Revenue Service in this country
and we do need to collect taxes the
situation as far as some of the imports
that we bring in it seems to me that
that could make up a big chunk of the I
wouldn't want to quote you on the 30
billion
but somewhere within there that that you
stated that would make up quite a big
portion if not much more also the fact
of privacy between business and a
personal transaction it was it would
seem to me that somebody doing this
transaction would already reported their
money to their you know such a legal
earnings to the IRS now if in fact 76
out of 79 business businesses and also
the what I've heard from personal
statements from people on the show so
far doesn't it seem that Congress being
we the people representing the people it
sounds to me like the law should be
changed yes we we have made some
suggestions yesterday to the enforcement
agencies in three or four different
areas one the law now said that if you
don't report the this money over 10,000
you can be fined ten percent of the
transaction we're recommending there's a
committee or I think we will that that
percentage go to 100 Nakota ten percent
on it is is not much and just doesn't
mount anything we're making
recommendations that says that if an
individual in a store connived with the
purchaser to fill out these forms that
they are party to the transaction their
co-conspirators so to speak and that
that would be against the law we're
making a recommendation that says that
if you deal in cash you must count money
orders or cashier checks when we passed
the law originally we said that cash
meant cash or currency it did not
include money orders that is a loophole
in the some of the cases here
particularly rayful Edmonds case here we
had one fellow said modern automobile
for seventy eight thousand dollars and
there were about ten different
transactions all but one were on
cashier's check that doesn't count
because that was not included in the
definition so we think a definite
should be cane now those are just three
examples of the type of changes we think
should be made and maybe they should be
more and the enforcement agencies
indicated that they would consider that
very seriously and probably endorsee
let's go up to Salem New Jersey you're
on the air me grin head hi I would like
to ask gentlemen about the SNL loss
scandal and I understand that the fic
eight is also in trouble the Senators
and the congressmen are supposed to be
monitoring this the bankers are supposed
to be honorable and at the same time the
American taxpayer is gonna wind up
paying for this why hasn't it been
monitored why does the American taxpayer
have to pay for the mistakes of people
that are supposed to be taking care of
this well they should have been
monitored more closely and I think we
would all recognize that they are being
monitored now we we have dozens and of
suits being filed over the country now
back where we think fraud has been
involved and those people ought to be
prosecuted and ought to be put in jail
behind the bars code they have fleeced
the people and honest people out of it I
think that the governor is trying to
play catch up on it I think we had lacks
a regulation we deregulated it at a time
perhaps when we shouldn't had but the
fact the matter is that we didn't follow
me as close as we could now a lot of the
credit I mean the blame can be put in
different places the cofactor the matter
is that it has happened and what the
government is trying to do now is simply
trying to protect the financial system
of the United States so it won't go into
collapse and I think that we must do
that as unpleasant that it is I think it
has to be done and I hope we can do more
modern thing as you say on these kind of
cases in the future next calls from
Texas Houston you're on the air
Thank You mr. pickle yes I'm a young
entrepreneur and one of my things that
my concern is I do believe fully that as
far as ten thousand or so should be
reported but isn't going to the small
business businesses now just a solution
because the small businesses are the
backbone of the country
and we seem always as the problem or the
solution let's get to the small
businesses and this has been done it
City does it's invented state and
federal well I would say to you this is
one more form the small business but I
don't think any small business should
object just simply filling out a form if
they receive a a cash payment of over
10,000 20,000 30,000 dollars that is not
an imposition let me take if you go into
a clothing store or department store and
you make a purchase what is for clothing
or refrigerator whatever it is you have
to you you will take a customer credit
card won't you I presume you all
merchants do and all you get from that
card is their name and their address and
information that's on the driver's
license you're asked that almost every
time you make a purchase now we're
asking less information on this item but
where there may be 50 to 100 thousand
dollars involved in a cash payment and
that's all we were asking so yes it is
another form but it is not being imposed
on your small business in any business
we picked out only those cases that were
generally classify these luxury items
and that's why we have we've chosen to
go that route Bend Oregon is next hello
I would like to ask representative
pickles now they're after these
businesses and he thinks it's terribly
unfair that businesses are not admitting
to every penny they take in and paying
taxes on it no not not not every penny
if we're talking about purchases that
are in excess of $10,000 in cash
so so not just every penny all right but
I would like to ask you how you feel
about the 1986 tax reform act the Tax
Reform Act now in the 1986 tax reform
act and I have this all in black and
white here in front of me if you're not
familiar with it but in Texas there was
written into that tax reform act and
this is only one of the many many things
that were written into there to give
private people friends of Congress tax
break I didn't hear you then no just I
think you mentioned there were tax
breaks in all right can I read you this
no I don't know I don't want you to read
it because we have a lot of calls
wedding but you have a specific question
regarding the subject I want to know why
Geraldine Ballard friend of Jim Wright
it was written into the tax code that
her estate was escaped the payment of
four million dollars right now that's
not really anything to do as far as I
can see or congressman community got to
bill and I'm not familiar to that but
let me say this
whatever you're going to read me I would
would like to say that that's not
correct
they're not a more honorable man in the
United States and speak the former
speaker Jim Wright and I regret that he
got brought into it now if you would
write me that particular incident that
you have reference to I try to give you
a direct responsibility but I'm not
familiar with what you would go to claim
go to Chicago for a next call call
yes you're on the air yeah I mean
Hispanic and I guess on Palestinian
friends and the big a small business in
Chicago and they send the small amount
this is some of the money slowly to
Jordan and then they bring in they've
been the whole amount all the motors and
they've been the whole full amount back
to the United States
I assume with the Palestinian and are
doing that maybe some other people from
different country are doing that to
clean the money and get away with the
taxes if there's anything they can do
about it I don't know that that practice
is going on if it is going on we ought
to try to put a stop to the best we can
if you have any evidence or facts that
you know of where this is taking place
and they're not being apprehended if you
let me know or any of us know we'll try
to have that lift in two let's go to
York County Indiana
you're on c-span yeah I've got a couple
questions you were talking about the
åland north and and Poindexter and so
forth on a special prosecutor to
investigate him and so forth and that
everybody should be you know no one
should be above the law I'm looking at
an amendment here that was submitted to
the omnes crime bill 50 to 69 to
investigate any member of Congress that
had been involved with Savings and Loan
and so forth and jack brooks and his
committee rejected any investigation of
members of congress or past members of
Congress that have been involved such as
Jim Wright Tony Coelho and so forth why
wouldn't the democratically controlled
Judiciary Committee let them investigate
all the people and let the chips fall
where they may
all right that's a little bit off the
subject if you like - yes that's off the
subject and that is a self-serving type
of question the Congress simply didn't
use a judiciary committee just a service
of witch-hunt against anybody who might
had anything do it the accusation
against them was just allegation no
facts of wrongdoing if they were then
they ought to be prosecuted me or
anybody should but that is a rather
self-serving question have nothing to do
with this issue go to Phoenix Arizona
you're on the air yes after watching the
program on c-span the other day and
after watching a other program in which
the senators were talking about the
selling arms to some of third world
countries I I kind of came to conclusion
that they're dealing with a double
standard and looking at
business versus small business reason I
say that is that many of the Senators
and and bureaucrats who were involved in
selling arms to the third world
countries indicated that they did so
because if we didn't do it somebody else
would and I think that's the same
attitude that many of the small
businessmen have in relationship to
selling goods and not reporting these
cash sales is that the only thing that
the small businessman is going to do is
be out to sale the guy's gonna go down
the street and buy it from somebody else
and thanks Phoenix yeah I didn't get it
great thank you very much
basically the question was if the
merchant was taking the money because if
he didn't the next guy down the street
would well you you can hardly condone
that in in law if that's the case then
nobody pays income tax because somebody
else wouldn't have to pay it and I think
that would be that would bring the
country down faith what we ought to say
is that we've got a voluntary system
everybody's supposed to pay their fair
share based on their income and if
you're making income and not reporting
it then you're violating the law and
we're not talking about the peanuts we
told about 10,000 and above when you're
going to buy condominium if they did
here in Washington and and you're
willing to pay two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in cage and the realtor
company said but you you deal with me
and I can work it out where we won't
have to report it now that's that's
terribly wrong for merchants to do that
and I think the temptation is first say
well you're your mother and small
business and you're left this alone
because we got to make a living and cuz
if we don't do it they gonna buy it for
somebody else that's simply not
defensible in law and that would be
defeating this country has it been
argued that that it's an invasion of
privacy no nobody's asked for that but
really all these farm tech is for the
name
and their address and the amount of
money that's involved in the description
of the property there's no privacy
invasion on that okay let's go up to
Baltimore Maryland you're on the air
okay great you know you're talking about
everybody should pay their fair share
you're talking about merchants should
report cash transactions in excess of
$10,000 I've talked to my senators and
congressmen and they say that what I'm
saying is absolutely not true they don't
believe it they look into it but they
never get back to me and let me know
what they found out I know it to be a
fact because I've talked to the Korean
and the business people that come over
here and open up businesses if I start a
business I'm responsible to pay
corporate income taxes or I'm
responsible to pay personal income taxes
or any type of business taxes that are
due sales taxes things of that sort but
yet my understanding from the Korean
community is that when they buy a
business the first five years of their
in business they do not have to pay any
kind of taxes at all whether it's Social
Security taxes federal taxes state taxes
sales taxes at the end of five years
they turn around and they then turn
their business over sell their business
is somebody else in the Korean community
therefore they do not have to pay any
taxes don't withhold let me just let me
just jump in are you familiar with in
that any type of no I'm not if if
they're doing business over here as a
entity then they ought to be paying
taxes here again it's not on this
particular subject but if you'd write me
I would have pastor that'd be looked
into would you do that
okay we'll hope that you dress up on the
screen at least one more time let's go
to Florida any pinchy
by cheap shaving cream only buy items on
sale I waste nothing but while I'm being
conservative and watching my opinion an
incompetent Congress and a worthless
administration has just laid a 5,000
dollar debt on my right myself because
of the savings and now all thanks to my
government on extra $5,000 incompetent
alright let me just jump in here again
that is off the subject but if you'd
like to comment well it's not it's not
off the subject god he feels the wrath
of a lot of people do over country that
the savings alone is going to cost a lot
of people you and your wife
over the years and that is a sensitive
truth the basic question is though that
that we've got to try to save the
financial system this has happened and
in some cases it was fraud in some cases
it was just poor business judgment in
some case it was just bad luck that he's
saving his loan and going under it's a
combination it did happen we did Reagan
deregulate and we let them get into
business that wasn't strictly the
housing or the savings loan operation it
happened you know so the question is
what do we do now
this particular something we're talking
about today is not connected to that I
think we all must admit that there's
some blame or criticism on any about
this SNL nobody should deny that but it
has happened and we've got to now see it
through the best way we can we hope and
pray that the Resolution Trust
Corporation working as if with the FDIC
can help us find a way to take this
property and move the assets so then
people who have put their money in banks
won't lose that money and that we can go
for it as a as a strong nation that's
gonna take money and that's gonna take a
penalty a lot of people and some of you
you may be one of them we all are but we
all work together and we're in just one
country I want to say this before you go
up there on this particular thing in
this case the the oversight subcommittee
of the Ways and Means Committee
it's simply charge it's looking in these
cases where we think people are not
paying
their share on whether we're giving too
much credit or where credit should be
taken back we're simply trying to make
it as fair as possible it's a difficult
matter and it's difficult for the
Internal Revenue Service to actually
always be fair one person says it's not
exactly a fair system and sometimes it
isn't sometimes you question how can
this person get by not paying any tax
and somebody face a heavy and and those
are kind of questions that there's just
no real clear answer to but in this
particular question the law says that if
you engage in transactions where there's
over $10,000 in cash it should be
reported that's true of banks and that's
true of businesses that's the law and
surely we must all say that we've got to
put some priority on these kind of cases
I think the Internal Revenue Service and
the Justice Department said yesterday
that they're going to do that and I
would hope this would serve as a notice
to the business community that all we're
asking in these kind of cases is simply
fill out a form if they're involved in
cases in over 10,000 that's all it ought
to be a rather relatively simple matter
and nobody should object to it we're not
doing it because we've just accepted it
as a matter of course they don't have to
do it and so therefore we're gonna do it
and we going to cut the corner but we're
losing a lot of money and all these
people who complain about what
government had done I would think they
would say that's right we ought to click
money if if transactions taking place
and that's all our committee is trying
to do
representative JJ pickle Democrat of
Texas thanks very much for being with us
George
thank you thank you Jimmy blue back in a
moment with Ralph Nader for another live
viewer Colin back in a minute